two GOP Presidential hopefuls coming up
with a strange way to get a bigger
bandwagon give them cash the vague
ramaswamy is offering folks a 10
Commission on money they raise for his
presidential campaign
in North Dakota governor Doug burgum
offering twenty dollar gift cards to
those who donate one dollar to his
campaign
it could be a play to get on the debate
stage hosted by Brett Bear and Martha
McCollum in Milwaukee on August 23rd are
you going to give them twenty dollars
and get I thought about it I figured out
if I could give the guy a dollar it'll
send me twenty dollars you got a Visa
card or something yeah but so here's the
thing is it legal or is it not the
question is
um and apparently it hasn't been ruled
upon but it it's illegal to reimburse uh
for a vote but people are going to jail
for that yeah but yeah but you're not
reimbursing for a vote you're
reimbursing for someone to get on the
stage okay remember there have been
cases where people have written checks
and the people of uh comments given me
the money to write a check right that's
illegal but that's not what this is the
question is whether or not they're going
to be considered a straw donor all right
and if it's a straw donor and it's
hidden then it's illegal yeah because
um if they're if they differ if these
donors are direct and they give their
name it should not be illegal but if you
get like a hundred people and you give
them a hundred dollars and then you want
2 dollars back or two hundred dollars
back whatever then that's not a problem
I never did this when I was running for
office he's a smart guy what do you
think about this you're saying I get a
10 cut
if I raise vivec fake money the fake yes
to all the millions of people that are
watching
or what
I'm not gonna go there but I couldn't do
that and I could get a 20 cut 10. how
are you going to prove it
put my name at the bottom of the
donations
it sounds illegal but what do I know I
don't think it's illegal and I think
it's creative and here's the other thing
who was talking about the vague
ramaswamy or Doug burgum before this
happened right so they've been on the
show the fake certainly has
I think he's been everywhere no no I
know but I mean in terms of earned media
attention for something creative and
let's just talk about Doug Burger burm
for a minute so he has the money to be
able to do it he is a very successful
businessman and he's trying to figure
out a way to get on stage now the reason
that the Republican party has this is
that they're not the first the Democrats
required this in 2020 because they are
very very good at small dollar
fundraising and Republicans are not
traditionally and they're trying to get
Republican voters a little bit more in
the groove of donating these small
dollar amounts and it does show that you
have a path to get on to the debate
stage and Beyond
exclamation point you have strong
thoughts about this well at least you
know everybody's been buying votes since
the beginning of time at least they're
making it transparent and I like this
idea of getting a commission I mean it's
like turning elections into an Amway
District you know that's how I got my
pink Cadillac from Mary Kay cosmetics
the thing is though you know this
doesn't work on Democrat voters because
you can't get money from dead people uh
oh good point in your face Harold yeah
yeah yeah this is what we've come to hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else